hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk about Uso edit Dori which
is a rear collar grab um I'm going to
show some of the hoki for it and some of
the the ways that plays out a little bit
I think a lot of people don't appreciate
actually how valuable ushiro edori is um
it's you do it all the time and probably
in places you don't know you do it and
also if you were escaping someone it's a
very likely thing that someone's going
to grab um if they weren't just tackling
you um because that Center collar grabs
a good way to get a hold to you so right
now I'm going to call Josh over here
we're going to go to work
[Music]
[Applause]
Josh all right we're here again for a
little more fast-paced action we're
going to talk about usir Ed dor and
specifically the hoki for Uso edori Uso
edori is a rear cigraph the way we do it
in my school is in yakui right so
meaning um that Josh's right foot's
forward while my right foot is back um
and it's just because there's there's a
good biomechanical rule of your arm will
be supported better if your leg or if
that leg is forward right so if it right
arm is forward then his right leg should
be forward and that that's going to be
good for him um and then it also makes
my job kind of easy in a second when we
start to talk about how this stuff plays
out okay so this is a rear collar grab I
think it's one of those grabs that to a
lot of people's like well why would that
happen but in truth if I was trying to
run away and he reached out and snagged
me that's a very reasonable spot I've
been grabbed there many times during
rondor happens all the time also if Josh
was going to just stab me or something
from behind he would grab me and boom
that's what he would do he'd go to
action okay so that's why it will appear
um there's really only four answers to
this which really break down to two
answers which really kind of breaks down
to one answer with a condrin so it's
kind of easy to remember although people
have a hard time with it often in my
school a lot of times students like what
do you do for editori and then I show
them and they go oh of course it's so
simple and then three weeks later what
do you do for editori okay so um
basically what I want to do is I would
love to turn to the outside of Josh and
when I do that I want the arm high of
the side I'm turning to so I'm turning
to my right my right arm is going to be
high now what I'm trying to do is
multifold at this point one I want to
create a ton of pressure up here at the
collar so hopefully that pops his hand
free and then I'm also hitting him as I
go through now if I do all of that and
it works notice I get a really nice
clean escape on that right so um that's
my main idea that's my number one idea
okay now that has to be done in a way to
account for what if I turn to the wrong
direction so look this is the superior
Direction because Josh has got no
attacks here right and we're in ioni I
recently put up a a little graphic kind
of talking about why Ian is better than
yakui or an ion me here so that's better
if I turn this way it's bad because
actually's shoot around here okay if I
turn this way it's bad we're yakui and
all of his defenses and offenses are
here and mine are too but if he's better
than me it's going to be bad right but I
have to account for this right so when I
go to that bad inside angle what am I
going to do well I'm going to do the
same beginning because I didn't know
that was a bad inside angle so I'm
trying to create high pressure here and
hit him in the head now it could work
his arm has a lot more elasticity this
way so a lot of times they'll hold on to
you longer but it could work that I pop
his hand free and come here and then I
have an Escape Route and it's not as
good cuz it's into traffic right so
here's the front of his body not as good
but it can work out that way right so
really my primary idea is to create
pressure up high in this I'm putting a
ton of pressure into his hand and I'm
doing that by Rolling my shoulder into
that collar and then this hand's
following up by hitting boom and I'm out
of there and of course if I had a weapon
in my hand that's all the better right
so as I come up here boom and goes into
them and and that's real great for me
okay so that's our our main ideas all
right now that has to be done inside and
outside because I I might turn to the
wrong direction I also have to account
for if he is too strong so if Josh is
super strong and I try to turn here I
will get about this far and I'm maybe
trying to hit him if I had a knife I
might be able to work him off that way
or stick or something but I'm trying to
turn he's just so strong that I can't
get through this I need an answer and my
immediate answer is to drop under that
here okay so now what's great is is I
opened up all of this stuff here I've
started really putting a lot of pressure
on this grip and I've turned things
around for myself now in my kids class
because they're weird and flexible
little kids they will spin about 40
times from here and I don't recommend it
but it will work I'll tell you even with
my grip after they spin about 40 times
from here I mean I could have punched
them in the face 40 times myself but
they spin even my grip will come off
right so so by creating this pressure
you're fairly likely to make it off the
second time that you do that right so
that is something come from it but a lot
of other stuff can come out of that also
right so as I turn and hit this
interference right here I can come up
here and I can triangle out and I can do
all kinds of different stuff so if I hit
that initial problem and I I train
myself to immediately sink under it will
lead to new possibilities for me
remember all this stuff has to be done
fast fast fast because there's someone
else coming in this guy's really big and
strong the more I slow down the bad it's
the worse it's going to be for me okay
so that also has to be true for the
inside as well so I turn here and he's
super strong going to have no effect on
him and I can't just get away I'm going
to drop under now this leads to ton of
classic techniques EO Etc there there's
tons and tons of techniques in there for
that but that's the basic ideas for the
hoki so I'm either going to turn outside
I'm going to turn inside or I'm going to
go outside high to low and that leads
into cages and all kinds of stuff so you
know in the forms you'll see those kinds
of things as hoki also um or I'm going
to go inside High high to low and that
leads to all this stuff that can happen
in there right so there's a ton of
little techniques in there that become
further additions to hoki but those four
which really break down to two which
really breaks down to one with an
adaptation is basically the work that I
do for ushiro edori for hoki for all the
escapes then there's lots of little
techniques in there and that's another
video we could talk about um you really
shouldn't be interested in my opinion in
collecting techniques from positions
because it's not really all that useful
however you should understand in the
position what is my hierarchy of things
I'm going to do and then techniques will
naturally appear out of that because
that's what the techniques are for all
that said I'm Christopher hin Joshua tii
and Mya Sal McDaniels hanging out right
over there right now she's waving to you
you can't see it but it looked like this
all right we will see you guys in the
next video thanks a lot
[Music]